okay for people who are joining this
livestream
this is our first dumb design meeting
for 2018 that we're live-streaming and
it is about a feature that's coming in
the next version of Wolfram language and
will be further developed in later
versions and it has to do with being
able to create chats in the language so
let's create a chat enable chat services
chat services are not enabled in your
preferences where are they in the
preferences well you can listen stab ya
or utorrent there under the services tab
in the Preferences dialog was it just
doing what it was enabling it for you
yeah but why did it take so long what is
it doing start up our kernel yeah chat
services uses a separate kernel and it
really launched that and its first
security purposes it doesn't show up
there yes it does it says chat tools
what is that kernel that's all I need
never ever remove that yeah ours is
called chat services that's just some
crust on your machine okay okay
all right so Who am I going to chat with
let's chat with Brian is this some
the okay button does not light up and it
should yeah and it okay and then it
needs some kind of indicator that's that
it's working right okay participants
will be invited to this chat after your
first message why because if you make a
mistake then if you accidentally invited
somebody that you didn't want to
then I mean it that's how other chat
systems work nobody ever ever sees that
you want to chat with somebody until
you've actually sent them something so I
don't see anything on my screen yet but
once again alright okay okay so if I go
plain text but yeah okay and how do I
send is there is there like the button
or alt enter like it says and I got your
invitation okay okay few participants so
eventually we'll be able to change
participants to I think from that view
but right now okay so okay so you are
you mr. green at this point so to speak
right well and I was not allocated it's
there's a cycling set of colors right
now you'll always be that color in your
chat and I'll always be that's this
color in this chat if there were more
people you'd see a different color I
don't know how many colors we have fine
fine fine alright so now let's say I
send you
oops that won't work will it why is
there no tongue oh there is a tongue
here an input cell works too there this
graphic design is not perfect in my
opinion like for example those buttons
as Billy with us here I mean those
buttons are a little bit weird in terms
of I wonder if this shouldn't be a
thought bubble button so
to speak to indicate that that's what
you're gonna get it's one of those and I
also kind of wonder you know as chats go
don't essentially all modern chat
systems now have little thought bubbly
things on there I mean I it's sort of
surplus to requirements and also why is
there so much space on the left here
that's to allow for labels if you have
them which they're off by default but
you can turn on and it would keep it
from jumping is some of the design here
and this in these notebooks needs to be
tweaked still and it's been that's on my
plate to do it's still respect for it or
not yeah we do have a spec Billy and
Brady can pass along you know think of
those bubbles are pretty rare although
alignment left and a right for who you
are and who everybody else is or common
I think and why does this give my email
address whereas this is giving just a
person's name right so we have a way to
provide aliases if under the window menu
you go to chat settings the actual
window menu at the top of products what
are you showing me here sorry
design spec if you wanted to look at it
okay and so this design spec has not yet
been followed is that correct not
entirely there are pieces of it that are
implemented but the certainly the chat
window here that we're looking at needs
some rescanning
okay so this this name aliasing thing
what is that is that it's not something
some variable I can see that gives me
that name is that in the user
preferences and things it's it's there's
actually a chat settings window it's
under the window menu you go to window
chat settings and in under the window
menu well it's it was originally going
to be sort of like it was sort of gonna
be analogous to the activity monitor and
that was why we wanted it there so this
screen name defaults of course your
email address like you saw if it's blank
you could put whatever you want okay but
so it's not a variable in the kernel
that is in the front end actually well
but that's not good enough because we've
got a separate set of things that we're
using right for the kernel variable that
you can set in the account settings in
the cloud
right thank you for information no it
gives me I forget what it's cool but it
gives your name and it's not cool screen
name either well when we were
implementing this the cloud version of
aliasing and screen names whatever was
still very much in flux it's not anymore
it's done now so why don't you figure
out what that let's see I can probably
find a version here are we talking about
the user URL base register new yeah
registered user name that's the thing it
doesn't do to completing and why isn't
this hey wait a minute why is that why
is this switched off um syntax coloring
that's what's that that is a consequence
of the fact that we have this separate
kernel that's wrong it's wrong okay I
mean we it's we've discussed it I've
discussed it with Lu inian and there are
some there are some consequences to
turning it on what uh perhaps slower
startup time I mean we're talking about
also it may would probably have to load
the light control equals framework and
things that are not well I mean okay
it's it might affect chat startup time
well then then pre started somehow I
mean if you I see that the problem is
but you certainly can start it at the
point where I ask for a new chat window
you don't have to wait until I send
something to start the the background
kernel oh it does it does start when you
when you do file new channel actually if
if you had chat services enabled it
would start at startup and then there
would have been a lot less lag while we
were working while while you were doing
your first chat here but uh it's for
that case where you don't have it
started where it might take you know
four or five seconds okay all right fine
so
registered user name is not being used
here why not seems like that's what
should be used his was registered name
just put in yeah it's new okay well I
mean that's why it's not in because we
didn't know about it well I'm telling
you but it's so we can all happily use
it and for some reason it's not
documented it probably is documented in
the eleven three that's surprising that
it's not documented there oh it doesn't
exist yet it's not not even in Turkey
tools really well maybe that's a mistake
yeah I made an action item for okay so
who is that who is I believe this is
something suitable in the cloud account
settings right I was just looking for a
dollar store name and I saw I would call
a registered user name okay well why
don't we check that with I think Agra
and Brad who should be involved in this
through the authentication discussion
okay okay okay
and then let's plan to use that if
that's what um okay so this is now chat
settings which does the same thing as
the window menu okay so this should
probably presumably this should default
to registered username assuming that
we're not confused about what that is
okay sure
yeah and if it's but if it's none
Enterprise UT blank none is the default
version or the default value right of
what music yes then this should come up
blank here yeah and there should be no
screen name but here right now yeah well
for me it's an empty string non you know
well that's probably wrong so if I do
that well it immediately light up it
doesn't change existing chats if you
started a new chat okay big effect and
then I mean that you chat a whole new
card that's silly I think that's true I
mean we can try it here a few
the next time you send something we'll
see what happens but I think it's you
don't to select it but that's actually
gonna send everything there anything
that's unsent in the chat notebook it's
sent when you clicked send button so
dollar registered user name in New York
City that all come through and you know
I got it
did you get it from the big bad wolf oh
did you get it from from s that wolfram
same thing that's what he's on your
screen there yeah they changed that back
so we don't end up with some stupid
thing if you don't like it out it should
just come back to your email address you
know okay all right okay good
so if
and if you're curious I can in fact
manipulate that manipulate and what you
sent I can direct slider - okay we have
a question from the livestream say
hypothetically I type in Brian's email
in I think this person has a pre-release
11 3 will it form a new chat or will it
join this chat if you go to file new
chat and start a new chat it will be a
new chat right now you can't join
existing private chats this would be
considered a private chat we'll also be
discussing persistent chat rooms that
people can join and leave it will okay
by joining that then you would join an
existing chat but right now there's you
can't join this chat okay so - okay so
you did get this some let's see the
these things have no tooltip which is
bad and no lighting up see that I'm
surprised I don't have a lighting up I
thought I implemented that but I'll take
a look okay and they probably should
have a tooltip insert a cell as plain
text or very obscure for some reason I
find this this thing here very obscure
why how can we help that as a way to
make it less obscure that this is an
inserted thing many of them saying part
of the original design which might not
make it out for 11:3 is to actually make
these things toddlers which doesn't
change the fact that they're a little
obscure but would make them easier to
use if you want to type a bunch of input
you just click input cell once and it
stays pressed and you can see that
everything you type will now be known
that's a nice to have but it doesn't
really answer your question um by the
way I don't know it's time this says
input cell this says plain text that
doesn't make any sense it's got to say
on it should be input text or yeah XLR
input so yeah text cell input cell
okay now the other thing we could do is
to say new cell once you have the
toddler it could say new cell colon and
then text or input see what I'm saying
yeah like once you've pressed it in the
press know what I'm suggesting is that
it says new cell :
and then it's either text or it's like
radio buttons oh you meant that the new
cell would be text before the toddler's
that's what I'm saying yes I also think
visually and the question for Billy that
these things should slide in to align
with the left edge here not be hanging
like that I think there was also a time
when that margin was totally to the left
I think that's I think in the latest
design it is that's fine so there's
something wrong until that happens when
you if we were to include the text that
says new cell that might help it a
little bit more because yeah okay well
they're actual bits that you interact
with will be to the right okay all right
let's go back to our agenda here because
I'm I'm okay why don't you send me by
chat where the agenda is what happens to
a hyperlink to come through okay Brady's
got it so Brady once you send a new
Chatman Stephen could see the invite but
he doesn't have wait a minute he's not
in that chat so I've got to add him well
no you can't you can't have people
remember but if Brady starts a new chat
with you then you'll actually get to see
the invite window and see what I find
that's good Brady go ahead and do that
please okay um hopefully channel UUID my
good lady has invited you to chat
doesn't I want to be bigger I mean isn't
that kind of a big deal who's invited me
I mean it's hardly a footnote who's
invited me yeah I think you're right
but Billy do you have thoughts
lilia either think somebody dropped I
think he's having had some trouble
okay well we'll take it back to him I
think I think you're right Steven he's
back now
Billy there's a question about the size
of the font in the dialogue pictures on
the screen okay said yes yes this should
not be a footnote this is the main event
blady invited you to chat okay then yeah
analyst
invitation could be you know if
anything's smaller but it's just you
know it's got to make it clear it is a
chat invitation but it's like Brady
invited you to chat I don't know whether
we wants us so that's the screen name of
that person right that's right and
that's the only thing we're giving okay
that would be the email address if they
didn't have screen name son yeah I get
it okay except rate is Jack now where is
that coming from did you put that in or
is that being added automatically that's
the standard that's the default you put
testing in for the title which is option
an optional field when you're making
yeah you know I have to say I think if
we're doing this could we put it in
parens if it's a difference just a time
if that's being used as the foe title so
to speak just for the whole thing and
friends do we want the paren yeah oh
yeah put that in principle I'm
suggesting that's okay well we fail
because I can't click that link huh I
can't click it either I can now click it
wait a minute yeah I don't think you
can't do that well I'd send you an
attachment I mean I can burden the cloud
really quick no just send it an email
then you can't give me a Dropbox thing
okay just send it in email please okay I
sent an email again did you send it
previously yep I told you when we got
here yeah that was the agenda email it's
like 4:30 something whatever it's fine
oh okay um so we have four functions
that we're going to expose this is
separate from the UI driven stuff that
we've seen the file new chat whatever
these are actual language functions that
we're going to expose all I'm actually
have a couple of comments on the live
stream here okay one is
how about a plus button that gives a
drop-down with the different types for
this I don't think we want that because
I think these are really the two types
of interest and if you want to start
sending section heading cells then you
kind of you know that's a more
sophisticated case these are just
toggles that are super common types of
toggles that's not to say that sections
wouldn't work they do come through yeah
they will work fine right second comment
is chat invitation as a standard cocoa
alerts just flip the contents for it to
work as expected who understands that
comment
I don't understand it entirely but it
sounds like a Mac specific thing but
Billy do you understand that comment do
you know what the is is what we've got
there that that's our own dialogue
that's not a system standard dialogue
that is our own dialogue but perhaps
there is a system standard for a chat
invitation which I do not know
by the way with respect to this thing
where it's pasting the why would you
want to paste the the chat channel UUID
that was actually your request if in the
future we well as you know as we flesh
out these language functions there will
be programmatic ways to access chats
programmatic ways to interact with an
open chat window okay well if that's the
case then why don't we
the for goodness sake let's paste it as
a string okay
don't paste it as plain text without the
quotes
makes sense yep scroll a new message is
that a toggle yes both that and showing
out labels or toggles so those in out
labels wouldn't know thar they I mean I
don't even understand what these are why
are those in ones down there you
evaluate a map before you value a to the
manipulate and it's just that's the
order you would have evaluated them I
see I see but these are not reflected in
your in out labels correct I don't see
an out labels at all okay well that's
probably wrong because you should
probably see the modern I mean I see
you're in out labels I if I turn on in
out labels I see yours but you're saying
that we should say that see the no
number you know I think so
by default yeah we'll have to talk to
the front end group and see how those
are actually hooked up I mean or should
we be seeing the ones that are for the I
mean in out labels are kind of an edge
case anyway it's really just for you
know in out labels only make a marginal
sense in something like a chat like this
especially when you have more people
when you that it's really just for look
back at my in 42 and then somebody can
easily find an input from you that was
in 42 I mean that's why we have them off
by default they're really not as useful
as you might think
sorry I didn't understand that you're
saying somebody is referring to in seven
or something you could say my in seven
but the thing is is that if I sent an
input back to you mine would be in one
so you would have an n1 and i would have
an n1 and so it's you if you have say
ten people sending in inputs they're
each going to have their own numbers and
they're almost certainly not going to be
in any sort of order right but knowing
okay but having the no number in outs is
definitely worthwhile
very useful no no we should have that
because otherwise it's obscure what's
going on okay fair enough I mean unless
the only case where I don't see that
being necessary is if you gosh if you
send a single cell that is the output
meow ba-ba-ba-ba-ba I mean if you send
the cell group it's useful to see that
there's an insulin out cell in the cell
group
if you if you send a single input you
probably just want the single input
right well and I mean if the the thing
that I was saying before the use case
that I was that I mentioned before if we
remove the numbering of the ins outs
that use case no longer is useful where
I was saying where person a says go back
and look at the chat history and for my
in 15 well that's not gonna be useful
anymore to say because the numbers are
all going yeah yeah I realized but I
mean I also I mean I don't know how
people I mean the point is we're
imagining a scenario in which people are
most chatting in the world happens with
people just chatting not being also on
audio see what I'm saying whereas our
use cases are a little different because
we expect people will be you know in a
class sending chats or otherwise having
audio as well as the chat so this
business about being able to refer back
to previous things as more relevant
there
it's gonna be pretty obscure because
actually oh boy they're gonna say those
times are presumably in local times so
for you yeah you live on East well I see
the same thing you do but yeah they
they're the timezone is switched Brady's
times would be central
so here for example you will see that
that will have been sent at 1556 for you
right and that will show up as 1556 on
your it does so the idea that one I mean
I suspect that we will want something
else here
I suspect we want the following thing to
some use cases we want literally a
numbering of the little number that you
can switch on that numbers the each chat
cell
what I'm saying
so they're basically like line numbers
in a piece of code yeah yeah it's so so
it says you know so you can say on cell
252 or something other words you know
it'll be at selten 52 of the chat I mean
that's assuming these use cases where
you have an audio channel as well as
having the chat channel well you don't
really need an audio channel you could
just send a text cell that says look at
cell 252 no there you could also send to
cell 252 again if you wanted to yeah
right okay anyway that's it that's a
future enhancement I would suggest okay
you're facing or just behind the scenes
no user facing because that's the whole
point you want to be able to know yeah
it's a point of reference mm-hmm right
so it'd be a little thing you know not
very emphasized maybe maybe it could say
here I don't know where that would
number would be I mean it could be
it could be along with the time
don't sayin a dot you know a big scented
Datsun than a number
Billy your comments yeah I mean I see
that I feel like it would be the
replacement to the time or I feel like
it's kind of strange having it next to
it because time is usually indicator
when you're like either doing text
messages or medicine but look because
we're dealing okay so maybe this is a
crazy case because maybe maybe it's a
case where we don't care about because
most of the audio okay the case where
this won't work is whether it's audio on
the phone where it's different time
zones if it's people sitting in a
classroom they're all going to be in the
same time zone presumably unless there's
a classroom that straddles a time zone
boundary but we won't worry about that
case um see what I'm saying so in other
words um okay let's move on because
we've got other stuff to cover so you
want it to cover where did I send the
agenda again
okay functions 4:11 three right so we
have four functions two of them are
basically just hooks into front end
tokens and that those two functions are
the function that opens up it does the
same thing as founding chat and the
function that does the same thing as
window chat settings they're very simple
there we did them because we could um if
you wanted to but the guide page which
you just opened up so we thought about
that do I have that edge explosion do I
need to update this is this is what you
said this what you see and that
tentative stuff is what we are
suggesting no or one version of what
we're no no we don't want this I mean
this is not the right place for it right
because I know it's right to channel
communication but this formatting stuff
is relevant to how you do send message
and so on okay I mean we could certainly
I mean it's easy enough to move
underneath formatting I was kind of
going back and forth of my head about
whether it should be under formatting
anyway yeah I think it should be look
let's move it um I think what we want to
do here let's what happened here wow
that's wild it just disappeared
well let me delete that well I can move
it underneath that's fine no no no no no
because we've got more things to do with
it okay let's do this whoops Wow
it's gone hey do me a favor click click
new function page in the in da key tools
and just close it just just to make sure
that da key tools is knows what it's
doing or I mean get folks page works -
that's fine yeah now just close it or or
whatever and now reopen that reopen that
guide page
now try and copy and paste it this is
probably a consequence of you want it
guide pages locked down and so there's a
whitelist of people that can edit edit
guide pages but da key tools has to be
fully loaded no no no guide pages really
I've always only the root guide page
you wanted all guide pages because
people were putting stuff in that wasn't
reviewed and oh you found it later so
that's bad yeah so this has been in
place versions so who is on the
whitelist for that it's a pretty small
list it's you and Roger and I think
Brett and me and all right okay it's
really quite okay high security okay
yeah all right what
I don't think we want to call it chat
features um chat sessions initiate a
chat session
why do we need to say that
you mean the full menu item that those
are menu item my mother well okay open
the chat settings dialog I mean don't
you need and I guess you do need that um
okay let's look at these then so what is
chat dialogue so right now this links
aren't actually those okay also they do
work they're just they're just not up to
date and that's fine but that way is it
linking to the the live page there why
is it not linking to thee because the
authoring pages are in the packet we
have links to it in the in the what is
this that's a system guide okay and so
those would actually pages missing so
there's an authoring page for chat
dialogue here or not there's not because
it's they're not system so is there a is
there a draft of that page uh-huh
they're out there in the agenda right
here just click the link it all give you
a download actually it doesn't well it's
doing something mess it's not opening I
can do seem at least you oh I try to
open it in a new version there goes
question on the chat distinct
huh huh oh yeah what happens if you
right what happens if you send a dynamic
delete file on down in fact here I'll uh
I'll you can you can try it if you want
even just doing like user base directory
just do like great dynamic a file names
of user base directory well so if I do
if I do here file names of well actually
let's just do dynamic of let's see what
is it let's say dynamic of Wolfram ID
well that's probably allowed through
because roll out through it's unsafe
dynamics or not okay so if I send that
so wait when when this comes out on your
side what does it look like
Brian via was not calm it's kind of cool
actually I hope we have examples and
these pages that show stuff like that or
by the way I assume we have workflow
documentation that's underway okay we
should we should put something in there
about dynamics it's not obvious okay but
we do have we did take this into account
and that's why that's actually why we're
using a new kernel so if you know you
won't be able to show but I if I if I
say use a base directory for example
it's not something that's locked down or
not user base the string itself is not
locked down but I think file type I
think it gives none if you so like you
can't you can't show ya file type of
dollar user based directories no to me
none it to me don't leave dynamic ax
okay so my own inbox mode basically yeah
it's sandbox mode
this screen is starting to get confusing
here because this gray color for you is
the same as the gray of the bar here
yeah he fixed with the upcoming rescale
that that's true yeah all that's
everything that has been sent is going
to get a kind of a lighter gray
background than everything else and
there won't go but then then proved to
me wait a second so I just didn't prove
anything gives the same result for me as
it did I mean is that is that this
kernel so if I were to say file type of
that outside of this kernel just in a
generic kernel yeah that's that would be
it would be directory why why is it blue
here that's because that's some I think
that's a bug because you copied it out I
came up in a previous meeting it's it's
not us I'm like you copied it out of you
copy it out of a notebook that has
syntax coloring turned off I think it's
just a front-end quirk bug well did it
get reported as a bug John was in a
meeting when you found it last time oh
man I don't know but we can check yeah
okay okay all right I mean here it's
there what dynamic of file names of user
base directory I mean I I don't know
that you want to evaluate that outside
of in a regular kernel but that would
certainly give a list of files what are
you doing nothing
because it's locked down and why doesn't
it complain
well alright that's that's not what
sandbox kernels do they just don't work
it just doesn't it just doesn't allow
the operations to take place yeah it
doesn't it doesn't have an indicator
that it would get like in the cloud when
you try and do something it's outside
the sandbox it gives you a message
saying it's outside the sandbox and
those very well may occur for those same
cases this is this is kind of a lower
level case I'm not sure of all the ins
and outs who did that stuff
Ian set up this kernel for us the you
know how sneaky set up this kernel for
us he would know but
I can do this because I don't understand
what okay so what are the cases where we
think it's I mean the main problem is a
dynamic are we are we locking down
things that I mean if somebody says I
see so that the concept would be if you
want to do something that is like a tech
support type thing whoever's typing in
our ears mute themselves the if if
somebody from tech support says here's a
way to check this or that thing will
delete these files or whatever else they
send it through here it doesn't evaluate
here but somebody can copy this out and
use in another notebook is that right
exactly
though why is it that the heading of
this notebook doesn't say anything about
chatting it seems to me that the
say chant notebook just like if you open
a template notebook
it says these claims template notebook
see I see now maybe that little things
are supposed to indicate that little
chat branding but we can certainly add
that maybe the chat banning is enough
but it seems look maybe maybe you've got
better scanning of this but but this
doesn't feel okay it's something better
gonna happen with these greys certainly
some of the greys I don't know that we
have anything in the pipe for the dark
self up there no but the other grades
that you talk about with the plain text
input cell bar with being the same as my
gray right it feels like there should be
something which separates off which
makes it clear that this bar refers to
what is underneath it not what is above
it so it would be good somehow and it
kind of is a different motif from these
these bars here to somehow put something
at the top of this that separates it
from the stuff above it and makes it
clear that it refers to what's below it
got what I'm saying I get what you're
saying I yeah I think we'll leave it to
Billy to figure that out though how's it
look ideas yeah I mean I think that bar
separating it as well as the changed
background when that scree skimming
happens I think we'll both be very
helpful okay but but notice that you've
got bars here which which mean the exact
opposite thing
that is those bars associate what's
underneath with what's on top of them
okay what I'm saying yeah they're kind
of like different visual communicators
still what's going on that needs to be
something other than a straight bar
maybe it's a dotted line or something
I'm not sure by the way another very
trivial point there's off by a few
pixels that dot is too low by a few
pixels relative to that font yeah those
are going away so what's going away yeah
that's alright fine
okay let's go back over here okay so
chat dialogue this dialogue may be used
to start a new chat okay so if i just
type chat dialogue you have to do needs
of chat tools first or get-go or less
than less than chat tools or whatever
that's that's going away right i don't
need to do that in the future well that
no that's where this is going to be
because this is all experimental stuff
no no no if it's being documented it's
not it's in the system context okay is
all the mongolian stuff and system no
but it is its document in a separate
package also document on no no no no no
no it doesn't go on a guide page here if
it is in a separate package goes away
and i think it should go here i don't
see any reason we shouldn't have it here
so please put it in the system context
okay i mean getting the documentation
pages in there is good enough getting
the code is we'll figure it out okay now
did we go over the names of these
functions previously or is this the
first time we're seeing them we've not
gone over them and that's what part of
this is going to be about okay
I'm not completely sold on chat dialogue
even though I was the one who came up
with it I think create chat might be a
little more analogous to what we're
doing
yes I agree I don't think this is right
um hold on let's just look here what is
create chat room now that is the only
without when we're talking about
persistent chat rooms this is the only
way to do that
you know we may not be ready to have
these functions does you
right these should be counted if we're
not ready for this um anywhere should we
actually not expose them in 11 3 at all
you can expose them if you want to but I
I don't think I not sure we should
document them let's good let's go on
going through them right now
okay well create chatroom is but well
right you have to actually specify at
least two arguments there's the short
name for it which if you remember when
we were using chat rooms during the
coding competition you know this is the
thing that you type up in the new
contacts field the actual name for it
okay so wait a minute this is so this is
something that's like like that or
something is that right yeah it's just
the alias for the chatroom and then the
second argument is the long name for it
the full name of the chatroom
and that should return right that's the
cloud object for corresponding to the
chat so now in mine if I type in xx five
three five and you can do this to go to
file new chat or evaluate chat dialogue
okay chat dialogue and just up in the
new contacts enter in xx 5:35 well it's
not what it says to do it says enter
wolf almighty's yeah well that's I mean
that's why we're kind of hiding this
under language level implementation only
there's no UI way to create a okay so
then what do I do
just okay I'm just joining the chat okay
but that's we should not have it work
this way because this is asking for new
contacts which I don't understand no I
mean this thing here is a dialogue for
creating a new chat this thing here is
the chat has already been created
language level which you think is right
to create I don't see that we need a UI
to create a persistent chat but then
this is joining a chat and I think
that's a different piece of function I
would say yeah
is I mean it's there are certainly some
things that we need to flesh out by the
way can I join that church on the cloud
as well I don't think any of this stuff
works in the cloud yet for reasons that
we've already gone over the service link
issue okay Brady already sent something
lovely okay what do what happens if I go
to this cloud object I don't actually
know if you wanted to interact with it
that's why it's returned from create
chatroom create that's what it is
well it's just really associational junk
I guess but it's what a chat needs to
work oh then we can we must in some way
are there display forms for cloud
objects do we do something like that not
sure I mean cuz all this thing is is an
association if there's a way to mask it
like you'd mask any other as well I mean
another way we could do it is to just
have this thing be something that says
this is a chatroom and then underneath
you know so long as
so long as we can programmatically read
from this it doesn't necessarily have to
be it ask the cloud team how to do this
because I think we've had a similar
thing for the channel framework okay if
you go to the channel if I say create
channel
that's interesting that doesn't come up
as a link but if I go type that link in
okay you will see something kind of
weird
Oh neat okay how about work that might
be something for all channel broke or
not well from that cloud URLs it might
just be a an override for everything I
think it is but I don't know how that
works and whether whether we can use
that here and why it is the case that
you're just using a generic cloud object
here I mean you don't have to use the
chariot cloud or you could have it be in
a different directory couldn't you I'm
not sure I don't think it's the most
important thing in the world but we do
need to make it so this thing the
results of create chatroom
honestly it shouldn't be this it should
be some kind of chat object sure but
chat object doesn't exist yet I mean
that's okay fine so this is a temporary
thing yeah and a lot of this stuff is
just we want to expose this for 11:3 and
it's not done it's what we can get done
for other three all right so then that's
fine then have it be in chat tools if
you want to document something as a chat
tools thing we're not going to link to
it from the system guide pages fine
that's absolutely fine it'll be findable
from search if people need it right okay
so let's keep going so I mean this is so
the basic concept is you are creating a
chatroom
fine you got well we should just use
delete object for this okay so seems to
me that we need two things we need a
chat object which represents an ongoing
chat actually it should be called the
chat session object and we need know
that is the chat room why is it a chat
room what is roomie about it as opposed
to just a session
a room would suggest because it persists
past your session doesn't yeah I mean
that'll be there until you delete it
yeah that's all and any chatroom you
make through create chatroom this until
you delete chatroom it so is this I mean
is the concept of a chatroom and we
really want to go ahead with that
um I mean that's that's old I don't know
what it was AOL or something style
whatever IRC stuff yeah um I mean we
certainly kicked around different
terminologies here a lot of a lot of
newer things used use the word channels
which which got really confusing
obviously since we use channels in a
different way right um just one second
here
okay hold on okay um
you
okay so I mean chatroom is really old
style isn't it I won't argue with that I
think it I think you're right I don't
know if it's still used but it is at
least people at least know what it means
um I don't like it it's really old style
ah okay hold on actually we have a
couple of comments and questions from
the live stream um if you click buttons
plaintext or input cell it will insert
at the location of the selected item not
necessarily below this gray bar
good points
it can also insert a new cell in the
chat itself no I don't think so the only
place where you can the only place where
you're doing editing the chat the
there's an extruded it's like it's like
one of those some you know printing
calculators you're extruding the
information up at the top here and the
only place where you can enter new stuff
is down at the bottom I mean correct
that would be nice but you can certainly
type stuff up there when you send it it
doesn't appear that way to anybody but
you and in fact like believe it it
doesn't what do you what do you mean I
mean there's send it should pick that up
and drop it below the bit the bottom
well no but it picks it up for me it
shows me that's crazy I mean if you're
not messing up the history for anybody
but yourself well so it allows you then
to annotate in principal to annotate a
chat but if you think this is crazy if I
might say so I don't think it should
pick that up and send it I think if I
want to annotate this chat let me
annotate the chat but don't send my
annotations get what I'm saying I get
what you're saying I'm thinking about
implementation details I yes
whoa I think we're gonna have to we
might have to punt on that a little bit
for 11:3 but we can we can come back to
that they're fine that's what I think it
should do okay second question is it
possible to have a chat with two
different computers with the same
wolfram ID okay that's an interesting
question
what's the answer to that yeah I mean
you could have you can have chats you
can have five chats going from this
computer and three chats for another
computer now they won't be if what
you're asking is will you receive you
know will you receive chats from all of
them on both computers will your see
chats from you know the answer should be
yes and that is true I believe that is
true you will actually be if you started
three chats on this computer went to
another computer and start two more
chats you would so for example in
particular if I do a new chat for this
one whatever it is well how do I find
out what the company is for how do I get
this one then I have to do copy channel
UUID
and then I we you're not gonna be able
to join that that UUID thing is not
gonna be a whole lot of use right now
okay but if I say new chat here okay
what is the thing do I do I get oh no
what what did I call that chat xx what
did I call it
Oh was it okay why doesn't it display
that here that will be very useful for
it that's the chat that Brady sent you
the agenda and you have that open
somewhere else you're right that would
be good but that's a different window
okay anyway this is now so that's my new
chat room so I've got to my new chat
room windows presumably if I could I
think you post your other one so I think
you have to open a second oh I mean I
think if you do this it I believe it
just pulls that notebook to the front
you can just press ENTER just you know
mm-hmm okay so it did that yeah so we
couldn't get to chats of the same two of
the same chat on the same computer but
if I go to a different computer than
your foundation what's that if you open
it up in a different Wolfram desktop or
in a Mathematica you could do that yeah
okay and then it will come out twice
you're telling me we get it in both
windows you know okay so fine so the
answer that is yes that you can have two
different computers same almighty
okay so let's go back over here we were
talking about chat room versus so I
think chat session object is clearly the
name of the session and that's what
should come back um what do we want to
call this thing that is currently being
called chat room we cannot call it chat
rooms absolutely crazy okay so now xx
5:35 now this again it needs an
indicator that it's starting a bunch of
stuff up yeah and it probably should
actually change the okay button to
something okay so this is two copies of
my new chat room to send me something
here okay so why did Brian get why is
Brian mr. green versus mr. purple it
depends on the order that that you join
but but it doesn't because we've got
we've got a one a green on the left and
a right
I joined first last time so I'm blue
both times I don't see I see I see I see
I see I see
I got allocated as purple okay that's
fine suggestion on the I stream live
chat or understand that suggestion this
is I mean this has to do with whether it
is a persistent chat so this would be
okay so first of all we've got create
chat session that is what is that that's
for a given I don't understand what is
this so this is so let's
there are two different kinds of chance
you've got persistent chats avoiding the
use of room and you've got I don't know
ephemeral chats and you know they both
could be considered chat sessions so we
have to come out consistent chats I mean
what about a chat channel if it's
saleable but is that the persistent one
or the non persistent one that's the
persistent one okay
is it correctly I mean it is correctly a
channel with a UUID isn't it yeah these
are channels
no no but is it but if you have a chat
room as you're calling it does it always
get the same UUID I don't understand
what you mean every each room has their
own UUID so what sense
what is the persistent thing that is
that represents the chat channel the
chat room it's it's all persistently
stored as a series of loud objects no
but you said the session goes away when
when when I close out a session it goes
away right so every trace of it goes
away so you when you delete chat room
currently if you delete chat room of it
the difference now between a chat
session and a chat room with a private
chat if everybody leaves that that
channels cleaned up it's it's deep it's
not being the thing that you make
through filing chat and type in your
contacts whatever chatroom everybody
leaves it's still there waiting for
people to join it again well so maybe
we've been aiming the new chat wrong
maybe it should say new private chat I
mean maybe they're two different things
new private chat a new chat channel
create private chat you mean well in in
the functions yes create private create
private chat create chat channel if
those are
and then but but then the next thing you
need is given a chat channel you need to
initiate chatting to that channel right
I'm confused now
I mean we're well we're kind of beyond
11:3 scope here but create private
channel you know how it would be fleshed
out as we'd have to have some like you
were saying some way to specify contacts
that you want to send this to
additionally you might want to
optionally send a set a first message
that gets sent through right away yes
but then also we're going to want to say
you know send message is going to want
and we may have a custom function
specifically for chat but send message
is going to basically need to be able to
send things to UM what am I saying to
the to the chat channels right by UUID
or by chat channel or by chat object--
or chat that's an object expression
right but then the other thing we're
gonna need is a a chat receiver function
which needs to because if you want to
set up a bot on a chat that's what you
need you need something which will
automatically respond when it is you
need something deployed presumably in
the cloud sure I mean that yeah yeah
then that would just be overloading
channel receiver function I mean we use
channel receiver functions for a number
of things in chat already being able to
specify a custom one I think would be
nice in some cases right so we also I'm
gonna have to go in a moment here
unfortunately the let's see getting this
to work in the cloud is important do we
know what the state of that is I don't
know if anybody cloud here is here I've
been inquiring too mad because he's
tracking the the tickets for that and I
haven't gotten a response in a while
I'll walk over there after this meeting
okay um okay all right so the things
we're gonna need here I mean I think
we're gonna have to loop back to this
I understand whether what private chats
versus persistent chats I don't quite
understand whether the weather the chat
object is different for those two
whether both of them just have a chat
object I mean even if you have a private
chat I don't see why you shouldn't be
able to have some way to add a person to
the private chat be a chat object that's
planned yeah I mean and these really
these you know a persistent chat and a
private chat work the same it's just
generally have occasion to this before
I'm sorry I I thought I remembered now
but we had a create chat and then there
was the question of whether it is a
specifically for IDs right id-1 id2 yeah
we talked we did talk about this there
were there were a lot of issues that I
think actually the last time we talked
about it you maybe weren't feeling well
and we we we we kind of tabled it
because it got very complex very quickly
because we're talking about permissions
groups and having you know it was
specifically when we were talking about
teacher-student scenarios where you
might have multiple teachers with
multiple students broken off into
separate groups of students that could
all interact with each other but not
other groups oh yeah right and we had a
grump we had a general Groff yeah it
gets really really crazy really fast and
actually on that note I started looking
at those old notes of that conversation
and and we were calling so like right
now we had created create chat room but
Steven you expect that is create group
chat do we want to turn these as group
chats again I don't know I'm not a
chanting kind of guy we shouldn't say
group chat because private chats can
also be yes I don't think that's right
but what I do think is we have a
suggestion here so chat room meeting
ephemeral journal persistent yeah those
are all relevant words yeah I guess the
room calls the meeting rooms when
they're persistent
we could research more of the can we
please do that okay but another point
here please
perhaps also disable cell print dynamic
of cell print of test update interval of
1 that's an ugly thing can wreak havoc
on your messages window yes I mean I
mean I don't understand why I mean it's
it's pretty cool to be able to send
something through with dynamic but the
main issue is not what comes through as
a piece of code but what comes through
as a dynamic piece of code
right that's the place where we really
need to be sandbox and things is that
somebody sends somebody a you know a you
know a grenade with its pin pulled out
so to speak or whatever it is
right it's it's less relevant if you
send you know I don't actually know how
these things work but you know if you
send the grenade with its pin still in
it the person could choose whether to
pull the pin out or not the problem is
something a dynamic where it already has
the pin pulled out right I mean it's
yeah when we went we did go over some of
these before some of some of these
issues before and that's why you know
that's why we sandbox like I said it
that at least covers the egregious
issues of filesystem manipulation no I
understand right okay well so there's
probably more to think about that there
are certainly annoying cases like that
cell print issue that came up that yeah
I mean it's annoying but I mean we've
got a powerful system how much yeah you
know you can do a lot of things how much
do we really want to block people from
being able to do cute very nice what do
I do here how do I get rid of you can't
you delete the output of our format the
expression and delete it the null all
right that's probably a sign that we
should be wrapping this meeting is this
gonna keep going forever I have to quit
this session probably okay so we need a
separate meeting then to talk through
all of these create chat things and
we'll end up with these chat graphs and
so on and we probably should think
through how that works okay well just
for 11 3 because 11 threes wrapping here
very soon we can change chat dialogue to
create chat yes please do and is there
anything else those others yeah
settings dialog which opens the chat
settings dialog yeah I mean it's pretty
simple but if anyone wants to do it
programmatically they can it was a why
would they want to open a dialog
programmatically no I'm okay did we
added it because we could
let's not okay go and create chat room
and delete chat room when she said
delete charm could be delete object but
I don't know that I think it's quite
late in 11 3 to hook that up fine there
how does it been the packages delete
chat room but but I think in other words
in the create chat room thing what are
we going to call it for now let's go
retro and call it create chat room but
we expect to change that later and you
want to package you want to meet you
want to change it still before 11 3 no
or ok no I don't I mean for 11 3 it's
just gonna be a downloadable package um
I mean it's gonna be a loadable package
right yep
ok I have to run thank you
see you guys alright thanks everyone bye